hi i'm alex i'm ria and you know us we
love food so today we're going to
challenge ourselves to try to make a
dish from the cheesecake factory but
instead of taking our time we are going
to order doradas and try to be our
delivery person hi i'm donald moore the
chief culinary officer of the cheesecake
factory and why alex and ria are making
one of our most popular salads i'm going
to show you how we focus on fresh
quality ingredients great technique in
all of our restaurants to make our food
before it's delivered to you from
doordash
[Music]
the almond crusted salmon salad really
exemplifies the modern food of
cheesecake factory kale fish and health
and wellness are in but it's still
indulgent and rich enough to be
satisfied there's 20 or 30 ingredients
that we're very particular about that
play a role in making sure the salad's
delicious
all right so i'm going to order on
doordash
cheesecake factory
easy peasy
all right jordash will be here in time
for dinner so we have enough time to
make something quick and easy let's
check out the recipe
all right almond crusted salmon salad a
lot of ingredients oh my gosh
i did not know this much work went into
it look alex aggressively massaging to
incorporate 12 times 12 times very
specific not 13 times cheesecake factory
does not mess around yeah okay we should
get going let's go all right what do we
need i remember kale brussels sprouts
and avocado
almonds shallots i'm gonna start cutting
stuff so since we only have one hour
today
i start cutting corners like i didn't
made a lemon vinaigrette so i just like
pour olive oil and lemon juice and also
we have to make two dressings in one
salad who does that we make all of our
dressings in-house and all of our
restaurants every single day the lemon
dressing is we squeeze fresh lemon juice
and then we add a little salt and pepper
a turbinado sugar extra virgin olive oil
from california and a lot of our salads
will add two dressings so for example in
this salad we also use a shallot
vinaigrette so shallow vinaigrette is
shallots and fresh garlic that we blanch
and chop in our restaurants multiple
times a day seasoned rice vinegar and
olive oil and you get this really well
balanced dressing which are quite
complicated to make
almond crust and a garlic chip is that
for the salmon
do we have to make a garlic dip
do we have pineapple
chopped by hand wow they really chopped
their
almonds by hand at the cheesecake
factory i didn't know so for the almond
crust for the salmon which is very very
critical we take almonds that we toast
and then we chop them then we have these
herbs that we take which are basil thyme
sage and parsley and some green onions
and we chop those up with a really sharp
knife so they're intact they're not
bruised you can still taste the
freshness we grade a couple of types of
parmesan cheese some romano cheese
that's done fresh every day add a little
lemon zest and that crust is all mixed
up and then baked on top of the salmons
after it's perfectly seared
this recipe like a novel
a little salt a little pepper it's just
taking a long time to heat up i think we
can make garlic dip
i don't understand what this garlic dip
is for so we make a garlic aioli or a
garlic dip that we use a little sort of
hidden treat in between the salmon and
the almond crust with lemon fresh herbs
a little bit of mustard so you get this
the richness of the garlic dip and it
adds this really delicious sweet garlic
flavor and we make it every day in our
restaurant wait were we supposed to put
the almond crust on before the oven
did we forget that okay we got five
minutes until the dasher is here all
right we were kind of rushing at this
point so we actually made a mistake in
not putting the almond crust on the
salmon so we had to go grab it and put
the garlic sauce and the almond crust on
that and then pop that back into the
oven to finish baking how much time do
we got not that much time left
[Music]
wow you're really going for it go bigger
place them around
[Music]
oh my gosh it's here i'll go grab it
hi hi here's your food thank you so much
awesome
all right doordash is here
all right i'm gonna go plate this okay
all right oh my god look at that
a little more bang for your buck with
this one i know we still
did pretty well i would say that did a
good job even though we cut corners
looks similar and also the crust is a
little bit more coated should we try
ours first
enjoy this one
[Music]
it's more fresh
and it has a subtle sweetness
it had the shallot and the lemon huh
all right so we did all right
but i'm gonna go with this one
well if you want to try this dish and
many others available at the cheesecake
factory go head over to the doordash app
and get something delicious delivered to
you today
try out the salad it's good yeah i want
to finish it you're in my little thing
i'm hungry i'm gonna need to help you